one of the things that I really really
want to emphasize to yourselves is first
of all
chess is hard but also chess is fun you
can have a lot of fun with chess as you
see in this in this final position where
you guys checkmated me you you created a
pretty cool looking checkmate right
that's pretty cool I mean just the
bishop and if we were to move the pawn
for example over here we're just gonna
move the King to the side for a second
that's Dale Nate but if we move the
bishop to a dark square it would be
checkmate in two I would move my bishop
here you let's say you would go check I
move my bishop you check make me that's
a that's nice now if you saw this in
advance you would want to do something
we call a composition how many of you
have heard about chess compositions yeah
they're also called chess studies and
there's some really really cool chess
studies now I'm about to show you a
chess study that is really hard but it's
really fun we have triple pawns double
pawns look at all of these things
happening now all of these pawns are
ready to Queen right they're just ready
to Queen now check this out but it's
White's turn but look at all of the
material that black has black has a
bishop another bishop an AI
a rug a rook but how many of us realize
that if it was black to play he would
take our night and it would be check and
mate
right check and mate it's clear so white
has to stop the checkmate but he's got
so many pawns ready to Queen maybe he
can overcome his material deficit so
look at this position for a moment well
this game this study I mean to say is
called Knight promotion Knight promotion
and try to keep a running count of how
many times white promotes to a knight
okay
in the first case what would the class
like to play again black is threatening
to capture your night with check and
mate if you advance your pawn and make a
queen just a second if you advance your
pawn and make a queen that would be a
terrible move because after he takes the
Queen and after you make another Queen
by capturing the rook white is helpless
white is helpless - Bishop takes check
mate so how can white stop checkmate yes
in there
and what yes exactly you would play pawn
on d7 you promote it but not to a queen
correct
so you promoted a pawn to a night once
correct okay now I'll play black I'm
going to capture your night with my rook
yes young man yes nice tonight so that's
the second time that's the second time
you promote it upon to a knight okay
let's say I play rook captures your
knight
yes young lady correct
let's where's the night there it is so
now you've defended this night so I
cannot checkmate you but let's say I
play Knight here yes young gentleman
okay
let's imagine that white takes this
Knight and then after I capture your
knight how on earth are you going to
defend so you cannot take my knight
yes young there yes you correct correct
that's the right move now I'm going to
capture your night yes it man
she's capture and promote to a queen to
a night so how many times was that how
many times have you promote three times
okay we're not giving up let's say I'm
black and I play King here now what
would you like to play yes young man
that would be a good move except for one
small detail
my bishops protected small detail what
should white play you can't move with
your king yes I'm lady correct now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to play
Bishop takes b6 what are you yes young
man what would you do with white correct
no I'm going to take your knight yes
young man how many times is that
promotion now oh four or five I think
that was five okay
that was five five times he promoted to
a knight that's crazy okay I'm now how
many think let me pause for a moment how
many think that the position White's
winning
how many positions how many people think
blacks winning okay how many people
think it's a draw still nobody thinks
it's a draw
okay so I'm going to play king here what
are you going to do what will you do yes
young men correct because you don't
really have any other moves you can't
move your king
if you move your knight I'm going to
take it so push the pawn now I'm going
to wait your turn what would you do you
move your knight but where can you move
your knight if you move it any other
square then c6 I'm going to take your
Knight and checkmate and yes young man
what would you do correct
okay I'm going to take your knight and
what are you going to do have six times
six times you promoted your knight now
I'm going to move my bishop back yes
young men in the red yes
be seven correct now when I take the
night
what's the resulting situation stalemate
stalemate white can't move so it's a
draw
nobody had it right you all thought
either white was going to him her black
was going to win I just thought that
that was a really really fun problem and
I wanted to share how many of you ever
seen any game where you promoted six
times to a night this magazine I live in
Amsterdam Holland and this magazine is
called shocknek chess play and it's all
in Dutch and I I read Dutch very very
poorly but they have all kinds of
interesting articles and I saw that one
and I just thought it was so funny I was
reading it last night mess and I got to
share that with my class so it was a
night night play night promotion how
many of you recognized the play the
player on the cover who is that do you
know who this gentleman is he's the
world's number one player I know he's
not Bobby Fischer this young man he is
from Oslo a city in Norway the capital
of Norway his name is Magnus Magnus
Magnus Carlsen and he is the world's
number one player I think he's about 22
or 23 years old something like that and
he's the world's number one player and
he's going to be the Challenger in
November for the World Championship and
the World Champion today is a is a
gentleman from India his name is
Viswanath and Anand and he and Magnus
are going to play a match in November
for the World Chess Championship and
they're going to play for two and a half
million dollars
I'm not kidding two and a half million
bucks yeah awesome right awesome how
many of you have played a game and it
doesn't get finished
like you know we'll play later right
like you got to go eat your dinner okay
so it's basically you all have
experienced the same thing that I've
experienced now in the old days and I'm
only talking about thirty years ago way
before you guys were born in the old
days we used to do a thing called a
German you play a game for five hours
five hours and if you hadn't finished
the game it was stopped and it was
called adjourned so what would happen
you guys know your score sheets right
this is this was the procedure they
would give to two players an envelope
and you record the position on the front
of the envelope in what is called a
diagram position right and then they
take the two score sheets and they put
them in the envelope they seal the
envelope and that envelope would go into
a vault where it would stay until the
game was resumed so you couldn't go in
and change the score sheet or change the
position and then the game would start
from that adjourned
position so I have the black pieces okay
I'm black and my opponent is a very very
strong international master from the
United States we're playing for first
place in the Montreal Open in Quebec
Canada and we got into a time scramble
do you guys know what a time scramble is
with the chess cloth when you got less
time and you have to hurry your moves do
you know it yeah you also you know it
you and you're down on time you got to
move real fast well that's what happened
us and suddenly and without warning the
arbiter comes and says time to adjourn
roof so we stop right here and my
opponent Norman Weinstein was on turn
and he he was white and he sealed his
move okay so I went and I had a dinner
and then after the dinner because we
were going to play the next day we were
going to resume about nine o'clock in
the morning so we had plenty of time to
study what is called an adjourn position
so let's see one feature of this
position was that I have one two three
four pawns and he my opponent only has
one so I'm Way ahead in force so I have
the much better position correct right
and it's pretty clear what Norman was
going to do he sealed this move in other
words he wrote on his score sheet Bishop
on d6 captures b4 and I knew he was
going to do that now I'm studying the
position right it's after dinner and I'm
looking looking looking looking looking
at the position and what do you think I
should do yes young men
if I move my pawn on a six up he's going
to capture my pawn what do you think I
should do young man
correct I wanted to capture this pawn on
b3 okay so let's stop and think about
this for a second okay if I capture this
pawn on b3 eventually one day but oh I
think I've got oh yes oh yes I blew it I
blew it
there's a pawn on 8th I'm sorry sorry so
white has a pawn here here so I could
capture this pawn on b3 right right okay
so let's think about this now I figure
I'm black I figure I'm going to push
push push push and one day I'm going to
force white to give up this bishop for
both of my pawns okay now this is what
I'm thinking ahead I'm planning that
these two pawns are so good they're
going to cost white his bishop and then
what's going to be left there's I'm
going to take this pawn and why it's
going to have one pawn that I'll be a
bishop ahead I think I'm winning but I
have a pawn on a6 which is going to
promote to a queen correct correct
but what square can this pawn promote to
and that's a dark square correct and I
have a light square bishop oh I won't be
able to win I won't be able to win
because it'll be like that situation I
showed in the first lecture I'll have
the wrong color bishop even though I
will be a bishop and a pawn ahead it's
not enough to win and I realized well in
that case the positions a draw despite
the fact that I'm ahead and material
that I have a higher force the positions
a draw and so I was disappointed because
earlier in the game I was winning
earlier in the game I was winning I was
so disappointed so I took a long bath I
took a long bath and how many of you
play blindfold how many of you can see
the chess position in your mind
can you see a chess position in your
mind well I had the adjourn chess
position in my mind and I began to think
and think and think and I had what is
called a Eureka moment I know how to win
the game I don't take the pawn I played
f-for my opponent played Bishop takes
before my I played F for just a second
and now look what I did I played H for
Norman played Bishop to D - I played h3
Norlin play King G one I played King G 3
now I'm threatening to play H to check
and Bishop b4 checkmate they should be
one check ok
I play King f3 g f3
my opponent waited with Bishop d2 and I
didn't take the pawn I played Bishop f5
now let's see what my opponent did he
played b4
advancing the pond I played Bishop to c8
so this was all the analysis that I saw
in the bathtub King age to uni 4 so now
I want to advance this Punk
notice that my bishop on c8 protects the
pawn on h3 Bishop c1 and I played Bishop
to d7 I'm waiting
Cain came back to g1
I played f3 Bishop came to g5 I played
King to d3 the bishop came to f4 I
played King e2 no pardon me now what am
i threatening my F pawn is threatening
to go right ok I'm threatening to go F
to check and make a queen so my opponent
had to play Bishop g3 okay so now what
did I do with black yes young lady
correct
I pushed the H pawn with check now he
can't take with the bishop because I
would go f2 and f1 so he had to take
with a king and then what did I do
correct I heard it but who said it what
should I do
push the pawn now my opponent has no
choice right
if he doesn't capture the pawn I'm going
to make a queen and checkmate him so he
took white pawn and what did I do
I did I did indeed
and now let's stop right here and think
about the situation let's stop right
here and think about the situation
my opponent played King h1 and now do
you think I should run with my king over
here and take all of these pawns young
man what do you check him 6 ok and then
after King here what should I do
young man in the red did you have an
idea no okay what do you think I should
do
yes yeah well if okay how many of you
have heard the word shadow shadow and
you know what a shadow is right you're
in the Sun and your shadow keeps
following you so we have the term shadow
in chess what it means is when the King
moves over here to take all of these
pawns White's kings will shadow blacks
notice that White's King just follows
blacks King all the way over but as soon
as sorry as soon as White's King gets
into this corner it's a fortress
right as we showed in the first lecture
earlier today
once our King gets here white can't lose
so we're gonna go back and we're not
going to allow White's King to shadow
I'm not gonna take the pond isn't that
crazy
yes young man in the red yes correct
that was the Eureka I stalemate white I
play Bishop to g2 and the White King
can't move he has to advance his pawn
remember the pawn that I didn't capture
white doesn't want to have this pawn in
the position because what does he have
to do he has to advance it so after b5
what did I do
yes young man I did I captured the pawn
on B thank you very much now white sand
stalemate what could he do and what did
I do
yes I advanced my pawn to d4 he advanced
his pawn to a7 what did I do
he made a queen he take the bishop and
now my pawn is going to make a queen I
won the game and I won the tournament
that was in the old days we had the now
if you play in a tournament here in the
club the rules are that the round starts
at a certain time
and you're gonna your time control a mic
time control means that we're going to
play the game to a finish but in the old
days sometimes we returned and we could
study the position and my opponent
Norman was very very unlucky if it
wasn't for that Eureka moment in the
bathtub I would have captured this pond
earlier and made a draw so it was really
lucky for me that the arbiters gave the
envelope and set seal you move
you